welcome everyone this is going to be an
announcement video I'm sure some of you
already know but uh starting today
actually in a few hours at the time of
this recording I'll be playing a very
strong classical event I'm in Las Vegas
got here yesterday
and I want to show the entry list
actually the first round pairings for
the tournament because if we scroll down
we can see
some big names uh Hans Neiman is the
first seed he originally wasn't signed
up for this tournament but his name
appeared in the entry list uh I think
just a day ago so a surprise a strong
player on top of the field and there are
about a dozen Grand Masters I'm the 30
no I'm the 29th seed and we can see my
first round opponent will be FM Eugene
unite who is I believe he's a
professional poker player but uh I've
seen his name a ton across various
tournaments in the US never actually
played him so it'll be interesting to
play my first game against him
and uh I do want to keep this video
brief because I have to prepare uh he
has a lot of games published in the
database so I'll be scouring through his
openings and trying to figure out what
I'll play uh on move one hopefully
hopefully beyond that as well and I
actually just went downstairs to check
out the playing room uh maybe I'll
overlay some b-roll footage so you can
see how beautiful and spacious the
playing room is I had to walk down a
little bit through the room to find my
board but uh seems like a very nice
venue
um I've heard very good things about the
organizers of this tournament uh it is
organized by the group 1000 GM and
they're doing a lot of great events
across the US for players to get IM and
Geo Norms so if I do really well in this
tournament uh maybe there will be a
chance to get a GM Norm but I'm really
just looking to play good chess have fun
and make some interesting game recaps so
stay tuned uh wish me luck in the
comments if you have questions you can
leave a comment below I will have
Jonathan schrance AKA vampire chicken
taking over my twitch channel for
various rounds I don't think we've um
have an exact schedule yet but if you
just follow twitch.tv I am Rosen you can
check out his live commentary and there
will be a full dgt broadcast I'll link
everything below so stay tuned and I'll
see you guys for the first game recap